[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in Drew Brees my good buddy
uh what kind of interaction did you ever
have with Belichick you ever have any
lengthy conversation with Belichick
not really not really you know we we
actually Sean Payton and him were pretty
tight
um we uh we actually scrimmaged against
those guys quite a few times during
training camp you know now that seems to
be the norm especially with you know
preseason being limited you know you try
to get those extra reps by doing those
scrimmages and Joint practices I feel
like we were doing that with them
um
before Belichick ever really was doing
that with anybody you know I think there
was a period of time where he he had all
these trade secrets that he didn't want
to you know let out and but I think him
him and Sean Payton developed a
relationship where I think we went up
there three years in a row I mean it was
11 12 13 and then we did it when we were
at The Greenbrier in West Virginia uh at
training camp so yeah um we did quite a
few of those but you know never was
there really like a personable
interaction
um I always felt like he was he was all
business and you know to be perfectly
honest I was I was all business during
during practices as well so it was all
good describe what you have here in your
trophy room for those who are listening
on radio just describe this in the
trophy room this just the office
wait a minute
so you have a trophy room this isn't the
trophy room
but now this is an interfere
um no I'm just kidding this is this is
like this is I got a bunch of cabinets I
need stuff to put on it so I guess we
put helmets and we've got our we got our
bats right here you know from that was
kind of a theme uh that we had in New
Orleans bring the wood whenever we had a
real physical game we wanted to beat up
on somebody there's some trophies but
man it's mainly pictures pictures of the
fam
um of the kids just stuff that you know
I can look at and gives me a little bit
of inspiration on a daily basis so
there's all kinds of stuff in here man
I've got I've got my bill Russell
basketball over here I've got Larry Bird
I've got
you know a Ted Williams bat
um that his family gave me because they
knew I was a big Ted Williams fan and so
yeah I got some cool stuff in here and
the trophy behind you is that the
supermarket
yeah
I can't believe we're sitting here
talking about the trophies that are in
the back here Walter paid Man of the
Year yeah there's some there's some good
stuff there wait why wouldn't we talk
about that that's pretty cool stuff that
you have like maybe give us a tour we're
here do a tick tock tour okay here's one
okay we'll we'll talk about we'll talk
about one of the coolest ones okay so up
there is the John that's the John Wooden
citizen cup so first off let's talk
about John Wood everybody knows John
Wooden legendary coach right UCLA but
did you know that he Purdue yeah so he
went to Purdue University yeah he played
basketball yeah he was he was like a
1932 player of the year yeah
um in college basketball at Purdue
University so that's that's a great
sense of Pride for me that John Wooden
was a was a Purdue guy did you ever
realize that when I made the decision
soon after that that became very
apparent so he's he's he's way up there
on my list of of
just legendary people of all time
what do you expect let me get to this
first then I'll ask you about tonight uh
what did you see with Tua on that play
when he got knocked down got back up and
stumbled
um you know what honestly I I haven't
seen a replay of that I've just read a
lot about it
um so I can't really count there
how often would you hide an injury
all the time
all the time
I mean look it's uh I I recognize the
kind of the delicate place we're in
right now especially when it pertains to
head and neck injuries like when it when
you think about
like the game of football I mean even
from its Inception is like this Warrior
sport you know and I I say this goes for
any any sport but any physical sport
especially which is man it's like don't
show pain don't show Fear don't show
like any anything other than the
focusing on the objective to go when to
go dominate you know whatever that is
and so
like look guys the rate of injury in the
NFL is 100 right we always tell
ourselves that right I get asked all the
questions weren't you afraid of getting
hurt no because you just expect to get
hurt at some point and you expect that
you're gonna have to play through it
like that's just the nature of the Beast
now when it comes to head neck injuries
I think we've recognize that that is
totally different and whereas in the
past that was ignored it it is something
that is even more important and should
be treated the exact same way as like if
you pull a hamstring and you're going to
be out for three weeks if you
you know have trauma to your brain
you're probably gonna be out three to
four weeks I'll give it a perfect
example Luke Luke Kuechly right one of
the greatest players I've ever played
against one of the greatest linebackers
to ever play the game played against him
twice a year in Carolina I think the guy
I that I saw had three concussions and
on each occasion he was out for like
three to four weeks which I thought was
was extremely smart for not not only you
know I mean for his case for his
longevity for his for his health and
wellness but just this idea that
like the fact that you can turn around
from a concussion in a week is is really
kind of crazy to me
considering that like any other injury
that you would say would needs full time
to heal I just I feel like that's that's
an area where we still have a ways to go
just in regards to fully understanding
it and the amount of time it takes to
return to play or when you're fully
healed but how do you hide a concussion
look you get you get you get knocked
woozy all the time I I mean it's it's uh
foreign
I think as a as a as a player and I
guess it depends on how you know if you
if you if you've you know experienced
that before right if you've never
experienced one before you don't really
know what it is you're just gonna you're
just gonna try to operate past it right
um but if you have experienced it before
and maybe you're able to kind of
self-recognize the symptoms I still I
still don't know
if you're
just
competitive you know drive or just this
feeling of like not wanting to let your
teammates down like there's just all
these feelings that go through your mind
of I can't I can't come out of this game
I have to stay in this fight
talking to Drew Brees he's joining us on
behalf of Lowe's home team you want to
give us an update on what you're doing
with Lowe's absolutely some GM of the
Lowe's home team have been for the last
two years Lowe's made a commitment last
year uh of 100 million dollars uh over
five years to fund various projects in
NFL cities have some great players that
have lent their support as well
um Justin Herbert Travis Kelsey Micah
Parsons among others current NFL players
um but guys that are out there really
serving their Community
um so actually last week I was in New
Orleans working with an organization
called
lower9.org Helping to build a facility
that was going to be kind of a
multi-work housing facility there along
with Lowe's so a lot of great projects a
lot of great work being done happy to
support it love when I see companies
that are willing to make that type of
commitment to to our communities good
for you good for you I know you've
always uh put in the time and the effort
with these sponsors certainly locally
there in New Orleans more questions
about the Bengals or the Dolphins going
into tonight's game Bangles
you know this was actually when I had
circled um you know from the start of
the season
um and and I was I kind of made the
prediction exactly the way it's played
out which is Bengals would struggle a
little bit because look you're riding
high off of off of last year's you know
finish
um and obviously kind of exceeding all
expectations doing what nobody really
thought could happen and then you spend
an off season by everybody telling you
how great you are right and then you
know the season starts and you stumble a
little bit which they had
um and uh look obviously Joe burrow
missed a lot of the preseason with the
appendicitis and that kind of stuff so
you know there were some other factors
there that couldn't have been foreseen
and then on the flip side you've got
Miami and Tua where everybody's you know
spending the off season saying you need
a new quarterback right and I I know
that feeling I've been in that position
before man and it drives you it drives
your preparation drives everything that
you do and you continue to build that
team and bring in a new coach they you
know built bring in some pieces you know
um and and now that team looks pretty
darn good and two is played really
really well
but I think that this is a challenge
that Cincinnati will be up for like
they've been waiting they've had since
he's had the bullseye on their chest for
the first three weeks right and now they
get to put the bullseye on this team
because this is the team that's
undefeated right coming in this week so
I think since he wins this game if Sean
Payton came back to coach and needed a
quarterback coach or offensive
coordinator and called you
look I I love the game and I'm going to
be involved in the game somehow
um you know last year I I went to Media
route
um that was uh really enjoyable
um I I felt like I learned a lot I felt
like I developed a great skill set that
will help me down the road whether I
choose to do that again or do something
else
um so I appreciated that experience the
reason I I didn't do that this year was
was simply because it was taking away
all my weekends and my kids are in an
age now where I want to be with them I
want to coach them I want to see their
games and that kind of thing
um look it's the same thing for coaching
right I mean coaching I don't think
people realize the life of an NFL coach
during the season yeah and then what
their families go through at the same
time I mean that's like seven months
straight of you know you might as well
be in the military on deployment you
know like they are like spending the
night at the facility I mean just
grinding grinding grinding and it's all
football
um so that lifestyle is probably not
what I'm looking for
um now I love the game I love the game
and so finding a way to to continue to
stay connected with it there's a lot
there's a lot of ways to do it a lot of
ways to do it and so I'll I'll assess
those opportunities as they come what's
like Brady is going to go from playing
to then going out to this site to do a
game and and it's not like you can fly
in on Sunday morning and do a game
you got to commit like you know three or
four days it feels like to doing a
broadcast if you're gonna do it right
you're going to spend the same amount of
preparation in in preparing to broadcast
a game to do a three-hour production as
you would to to play the game now
look you can you can structure that
schedule a little differently you can do
it you know during the week when the
kids are at school I mean you know
you're home in the evenings when maybe
otherwise you would I mean so yes it's
not it's not as intense as as if you're
a player but at the same time if you
want to be great at anything you got to
work at it
um and I think uh you know I'm not sure
exactly what Tom is signed up to do you
know um I know what's been announced
um but it is it is definitely a
commitment and it takes more time than
you think and I think that that's I
definitely have a a respect for the guys
that are in those positions and the guys
that really do it the right way uh you
know the preparation that goes into that
great to catch up with you again hope
the family is well good luck with Lowe's
uh home team there
thanks DP see you man that's Drew Brees
Super Bowl MVP played 20 Seasons uh led
the NFL in passing yards seven times led
the NFL in passing touchdowns four times